cette semaine que peuvent faire les
peuples autochtones contre les
changements climatiques ou est bienvenu
espace autochtone 6 et mélissa mollen
dupuis pour répondre à ta question sacha
les premières nations les peuples
autochtones et communautés à travers le
monde ont des manières d'aider aux
changements climatiques parce qu'ils ont
justement je tairai le premier impact
des changes mais matic d'ailleurs on
parle même plus de changements
climatiques on va parler de catastrophe
climatique où les enjeux sont réels mais
comment est-ce qu'on peut participer
mais je pense que c'est en partageant
nos savoirs traditionnels en partageant
nos pratiques ancestrales
parce que ce sont des sciences
autochtone qui n'appartiennent pas
uniquement aux autochtones mais elles
appartiennent à l'humanité
ce sont des savoirs que je crois
l'humanité posséder
dès les débuts mais malheureusement à
travers les colonisations à travers le
développement en europe justement de
système politique
beaucoup de ces savoirs qui
appartiennent à l'humanité ont été
oubliés et ont quand même été conservé
au canada aux états unis un habitude en
fondant l'île de la grande tortue
jusqu'à l'arrivée des premiers colons
parce qu'on était dans des territoires
restreints on devait circuler on devait
vivre en symbiose avec ses territoires
et ces pratiques là nous ont permis
justement de rester dans des territoires
resterait alors que les pratiques qui
venait d'outre-mer en fait que justement
il pouvait pas rester sur ce même
territoire leurs pratiques les forcer à
aller coloniser d'autres territoires
donc pourquoi les savoirs ancestraux
autochtone ne font pas partie justement
de céder ces données là c'est que quand
il ya eu la colonisation
malheureusement ces savants la honte est
vue comme arriérée ou sauvage donc eu
beaucoup de préjugés par rapport aux
connaissances qu'on avait du territoire
malgré que ils ont été utilisés pour
coloniser le territoire jeudi à
l'arrivée des européens
quand même été parsemée de beaucoup de
défis justement liée au territoire il ya
vivent en symbiose avec ce territoire
est aujourd'hui mais si on regarde le
livre de la science de l'humanité et à
un gros paragraphe manquants et ça c'est
souvent parce que le milieu scientifique
humain faisant des erreurs en excluant
les savoirs autochtones en excluant
les personnes de couleur ou les
personnes autochtones dans ces milieux
scientifiques ou même accéder à
l'université
donc aujourd'hui on voit qu'il dira un
meilleur culpa du milieu scientifique de
reconnaître justement c'est savoir le
commettant des sciences qui font partie
justement de du livre de la science de
l'humanité puisque souvent on va faire
des grandes découvertes
eureka sur des sujets et les communautés
autochtones monde sont le savait depuis
longtemps donc en reconnaissant
justement la validité des savoirs
ancestraux la validité des pratiques
traditionnelles le milieu scientifique
justement remet en place ces sciences de
corps connaît maintenant comme étant des
sciences parce que la science en tant
que telle la structure de sciences et
l'observation d'un fait et de rapporter
cette observation là et de l'appliquer
dans les minutes dans lequel on vit
c'est pas mal ça la science sait juste
qu'elle n'avait pas le modèle euros ça
après qu'on connaît d'ailleurs je
recommande une lecture très intéressante
que je suis en train de faire moi même
c'est breeding suis grâce tressé le foin
d'odeur c'est au niveau de robes noires
caméra est dedans on parle justement de
l'inclusion des savoirs traditionnels
dans le milieu scientifique de ces
apprentissages de qui vont améliorer
justement la pratique scientifique et
pourquoi ces solutions aulas sont
importantes c'est qu'il faut arrêter de
chercher une pilule aux catastrophes
climatiques au changement climatique
il faut se rendre compte que c'est un
changement de comportement total qu'il
faut faire c'est un comportement au
niveau social au niveau communautaire
dans les changements qu'on fait tous les
jours et justement dans les savoirs
ancestraux il y a des pistes de solution
au changement climatique
donc je pense que c'est l'apport que
justement les communautés peuvent faire
c'est d'amener ces savoirs et de les
partager
parce qu'on continue de tendre la main
et de vouloir partager ses savoirs là et
c'est au milieu scientifique et aux
communautés notre tente justement de les
intégrer dans leurs savoirs et de voir
que la vision des premières nations
permet justement de survie de l'humanité
dans des conditions de catastrophes
climatiques
merci beaucoup pour la question j'espère
y avoir répondu j'espère que vous
n'hésiterez pas à nous envoyer des
questions et à partager cette vidéo
alors je vous souhaite une belle semaine
de la part de l'équipe de parole
autochtone